finger prank that students pulled off at
St Andrews School in Delaware they
surprised a teacher in her home yes in
her home with a little help from her
husband the entire senior class slept
over here's the moment when she came
down for her morning coffee check it out
good morning little bunny
oh my God
and all of you you might want to walk
around the entire clip is hilarious
because initially she walks in slams the
door right away she's like who are these
people on my floor and then she opens
the door and sees even more kids
surprise and they all laugh and giggle a
big time surprise these senior pranks
are getting really really creative by
the way yeah okay all right I hope they
got a good relationship between the
teacher they can't pull it off
everything a lot of teachers are at home
thinking I hope they don't do that